this is as much as you will get from me
about
[Music]
life to ask you a question you ask in
Hegel in a wide brain are we living in a
dystopian time or a time of dystopian
fantasies or both uh it's a very good
question because this difference is
crucial the only way I can account for
it let me be precise which difference
precisely are we really more or less
approaching some kind of end or is it
just that in a strange way we are
obsessed by the end I think both are
true but not in the sense of Harmony the
explanation I have is that we at the
same time we live in an era of what I
call following my conservative German
friend Peter slauter we live in an era
of cynical reason where you know in the
old times the disavowal worked like this
you knew something is true but you
pretend that it's not true and you or
you try to explain it away and so on now
we are entering a new era I have in my
next book but also can impr lator of
science where uh we learned we those in
power not me we learned
how to tell objectively at the level of
facts the truth but this very fact
immobilizes
us precisely the fact of talking about
it instead of mobilizing us makes us
apathetic inefficient and so on for
example even at the level of art because
I'm here not at the other place is there
another place in K I don't know I can't
remember forgot because if there is a
thing I hate and one of the things where
I am tempted to act as a terrorist like
a bomb there it's this big art
banales Venice castle and so on did you
notice something about them how uh in
their programmatic notes to begin with
they say we are all under capitalism we
are part of exploitation
eurocentric racist blah blah blah and
then they go on and the way castle and
Venice functions are perfect examples of
pure capitalist uh commercialization of
art you see the Paradox you are telling
it what it is and instead of preventing
you it goes on wasn't the same with uh
no it was a little bit north two years
ago when you remember the Glasgow
conference on the prince now no longer
just Prince Charles was there and in
some stupid sense although it's not as
he basically told the truth danger blah
blah blah but nothing came out of it and
this is very close to me now I enter
this is as much as you will get me from
me about life I know that stance because
I have it it's the obsessional neurotic
stance you talk all the time not to
achieve something but to make it sure
that nothing will happen that's why
another detail from life when I was 50
years ago 40 in psycho analysis you can
imagine how it looked it was a lan
psycho analysis which means I could be
sure that the session will not last more
than 5 seven minutes so I talked all the
time why because I was afraid that if I
stop talking for a second the analyst
will ask me some really embarrassing
question so you see this idea of being
active to make it sure that nothing will
really change to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or Visit ii. TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest
ideas